dakari were you making that up about his
name that's a pot yeah the Swedish Park
no it's true
did you know this what tell him tempeh
is a Swedish for vagina so I have a kind
of attack
but I was like why why why are you Thani
know why but is if that's true I know
why I know why what I don't know what
I'd say because I heard that when you
were trying to figure out your name you
know like your your music name that you
want that you looked up anger right
yeah and that and then you're like oh
temper like tempo yeah wow I'm so proud
Wow nobody googled a guest performance
he's back in the dressing room do on
this couch last names you gotta be yeah
I'd be up on why I'd be ready if we had
all your names it's like the ultimate
Scrabble score all delevingne it's it's
good it's good right
everyone go let's make yeah this week's
is it by PI Clarke Cooper yeah your
center shoes who cares
let's make this week's visit to the red
chair here's their who's there hello hi
Oh oh yeah
my god
that card it'll be